Did you, did you ever yourself drink that?
I know that much, obviously, but does much more than you should. I mean.
More than one.
And I was, uh, I was, uh,
not far off being an alcoholic at one point I was drinking far too heavily.
What kind of [inaudible] for down my throat? I mean, I was,
and I was, uh,
I had this discipline where I wouldn't drink after thirsty in the week.
So didn't do a show on Saturday. So I had three days where I'd,
I suppose I kept me sane, but, uh, I went,
I sought psychiatric help and, uh, I had that and uh,
I went to a doctor and all of that, and then he just put me straight. He said,
listen, in the end, it's up to you.
If they do want to keep on drinking and maybe die from brain can lose your
career. And I thought that's a no brainer, but I knew be drunk.
Still think of it that way. You see the thing of the good times the having,
how did Mary handle it very well? I mean,
she was big pitiless or she's someone said to me, I mean,
she was the real reason why I changed. She said to me,
do you know what your problem is when you're drunk? And I said, no, she said,
you're ugly. Try that.
Oh, you're welcome. Thank you.
This is kind of surreal for me. Uh, as I have stolen so much from you,
um, even the chairs, I know this, that I told them.
I found my old chairs from the series I did here. Um,
I obviously, you, you were, you were always well-prepared. I mean,
you're famous for that, but, but, but did you also have a need for control?
No, I don't think you can not see it.
You can't go in there thinking it's a wrestling match. It's that sphere.
It's a dialogue between two people.
And there comes a moment in time when you you've snared them,
maybe where you are getting closer and closer to that relationship.
Sometimes it doesn't work,
but it's the most fascinating job in all of television.
I think the other thing that Intuit is really,
really fascinating is to down and analyze what it is that happens.
The difference between men and women. I mean, men are not collegiate at all.
Men will come on like iron here, first guests, and then move there.
The man comes on and he sits like that. You've seen that women don't do that.
They turn right. They talk to their collegiate.
And that's what a wonderful thing to do in groups of people because they gossip
naturally amongst the men don't want to do that. They're competitive,
all those little things that, you know, go to make up. They,
the fascination of this job.
Did you, did you always have those three questions ahead?
No, I just said the one. I mean, I,
I have a very good memory and I go down a, an Avenue and are going,
then I go to a crossroads there and I go right to our left,
depending on what's happened. You, you have to plot it in a very loose way,
but you have to plot it and you have to do the research,
even though that otherwise you're, you're Patty.
You're going to see that life though. Terribly.
I mean, you're, you're sitting here now with, with an actress and a comedian.
Yes. Uh.
Get ready North country comedian ever met them.
[inaudible] big laugh. I love comedians. Are these the most physical job.
Do you think though, as, as, uh, as guests, were they easier than the actress?
They, they, they weren't, it's a typical job. It's a tough job. And also too,
if they're coming on,
they're not doing their routine and they're trying to answer your could have
aggression. It's difficult for them to be funny, as funny,
as good as the routine,
but that if you get one going that they're just worthwhile. I mean,
Billy Connolly was my favorite comedian, uh, Robin Williams, people like that,
that wonderful a woman. What was the name? Oh, the Jewish lady.
Oh yeah. Uh, uh,
Jewish woman. She does her own talk show.
She was a janitor. Joan Rivers, Joan Rivers, for instance. I mean,
she was wonderful, extraordinary.
She really was loved her dangerous and all that sort of thing.
And extremely funny in your show. I mean, the thing that that's,
that's the most difficult thing in the world and you'll know this better than
anybody else is to make somebody laugh. It really is.
And it's the most difficult thing is to do it cold as well in a kind of
situation like this. But when it happens, when it works, it's magical,
makes all those frustrating days worthwhile.
Do, do you think, do you think Michael,
that there is a difference between celebrity today and celebrity back.
Then? I mean, when I started so residue of Hollywood, you know,
so I started interviewing in 1950,
Danny 63 interviewing on television. That is,
I'd done a lot before that immediate, but the difference was it,
when I said ladies and gentlemen, my next guest is feather stair.
They never seen predecessor alive. They don't only see 30 foot high on a screen.
They didn't have Facebook to find out all about predecessor,
to know all about the mountain or the woman when they walked on.
And that's a big difference.
I feel sorry for him to do this today because there's no mystery.
There's nothing to unravel.
I had a story which I could pick out and tell and hold them in fascination,
hopefully, but today they know it. They know the story. Entertain me.
Tell me another joke. I've heard that one where you go, you know,
very difficult. Indeed. I had the best of it without a single shadow of a doubt.
And I'm rather than glad I'm not doing it today because it's been much more
difficult. I had a cakewalk. I walk everywhere.
Did, did you, did you find it difficult to find the right, the right timing for,
for, for ending it? Oh, I do.
I mean of them space.
You've got to ask the question to which there's an interesting answer and all
that stuff, you know,
but it was better when you talk to people who hadn't expressed their life
open fully to people. And also when they had a career, I mean,
some of these people actually, like feather said, they made a hundred movies.
I mean, there weren't just like one or two overnight success.
These are great stars. When I said ladies and gentlemen,
my next guest is James Cagney. There was a gasp in the audience, you know?
I mean, James Cagney, would we ever see him like this? No, not at all.
They never had. So it was wonderful. It was like, you know,
going around a wonderful museum for the very first time and pointing up people
in glass cases.
Where are you aware of that at the time?
No. Well, yeah. Well, I was aware of the fact that I was,
I was privileged because what happened when I first started in the television
business, it coincided with Hollywood align the stars,
freedom up until that point. They're not allowed, this is early sixties, 63.
They're not allowed people to go on television.
I thought because the television was a devil, spawn,
television would ruin everything, all that sort of thing.
Eventually they got the message and then allowed them on. And of course,
so therefore I was there right in the very beginning when it all came flooding
down the stairs and it was marvelous. I.
I know that you had a special soft spot for a Swedish actress, uh,
ethylene. Well, uh, there's another one.
[inaudible].
Oh, Ingrid, Bergman. I first love. Yeah, absolutely.
Of course. Anybody who was sobering because the blanket fell for her. I mean,
her director took two days to lighter and they said, why you're taking so long.
And if it goes, when they see or the audience,
every mother has to fall in love with it, we all did.
And how old were you then?
I suppose that'd be about 12.
I don't taste.
One thing.
What's the biggest sense of trust between a celebrity or the journalists
back then? Because now,
nowadays you can't really control where the information goes.
It's a very interesting, important.
They too were the reaction that you get on Instagram and stuff like that.
You know, the, the, these awful trolls come in and say terrible things,
or he looked awful and I saw them. They didn't have that at all. So yes,
there will be supremely competent. I think from that point of view, again,
you raise a very interesting point. I mean, fancy doing an interview.
They've been frightened of what they're going to say about you on the internet.
I think that that it's an impossible task. Really. Have you done that? Did it,
that I could, I would hate to do it now.
Have you, as a person ever been shy, shy, I'm quite shy.
I've been here shy all my life, but I took me a long time to get married. I was,
no, I'm not, I'm not, uh, I'm not an extrovert in that sense at all.
Although when I'm, when I'm working, then,
then you'll have to have a confidence in what you do.
And that's a different thing. Then you're not allowed to be shy.
You have to be somebody else in a sense. It's an act. We all know.
So how, how did you meet? I mean, you're, you've been married for like 60 years.
60 Years this year.
This is amazing.
[inaudible] we have a lot of divorces in Sweden and Norway,
so that's why they're so, so how did you,
how did you manage to get hurt? Well, I've never in all my life.
Further away than 10 miles from there. My wife, because we were bought up in,
uh, in the mining area in Yorkshire,
Amelia was father worked in one Caulfield and my dad worked in the other code.
So without knowing that we met eventually when I was a journalist and a local
paper, uh, she was a school teacher.
She was going off to a meeting on a bus and I sat next to her.
I fell in love with her.
No, no. I got a friend to tell her, you got a friend.
The date. And, uh, and then from that point on.
Any questions for her.
No predator scenario, but I wanted to actually,
she had a boyfriend at the time and I wanted to go to the,
to the hotel where we danced in this Saturday evenings. And I wanted to,
to play on the, the band to play a certain song.
And at that precise moment in time, as it played out,
I wanted to interrupt him and said, uh, pardon me?
But I'd like to dance with your father. And he was said to me, she's buying.
I said, no, she's buying. I'm going to marry you.
I didn't do that.
[inaudible] no, no, no, no. I don't. I, you.
Through the friend and I, we, we had a romance and a nice romance and I,
I proposed to it and the sea front it's calm.
And, uh, and we've been married.
We've got three children and we've got five grandchildren and everything's fine.
I mean, we're very happy. Uh, Mary looks wonderful.
She still is as attractive as ever.
And of course she had an extraordinary career. She was a teacher.
And then when I was doing an afternoon show on ITV, uh, uh, uh,
show him brilliant women very early on, uh,
she was asked by the problem of control that he asked me,
would I mind if he screen tested her? Gosh, she looks fantastic.
And she did the screen test and she was she a very bright lady and she became a
very good into it. And this is one of my favorite stories of all.
I was sitting next to a high powered Tory politician at the time.
And this is such a, there's an eventful about school milk.
She actually bounced called milk.
So my wife being an ex-teacher was up in arms about this.
So they sent the junior minister down to talk to Mary about this situation,
started the show. I started the show, LinkedIn to her,
and the next thing that he was a tutorial, Grandy, a real tutorial or whichever.
And he was looking at this young minister who was trying to deal with Marianne
mate, tore him apart. Absolutely brilliantly destroyed him.
And it ended up in an argument in any case. But in the end,
when she finished and handed back to me to go into a break,
he was on the floor and ashes,
and I could feel his Tory Grundy to be tiny like this,
just this demolition job went on.
I remember I got linked into the commercial brick. He turned to Bishop.
Good God, if I didn't see that, I said, I did. He said,
I'd hate to be married to her.
[Inaudible] if you think, if I asked her if she's known you for 60 years,
since before you became Parkinson's, um,
do you think she would say that television changed you?
Yes, I think so. I think she might say that. And I think it does. I mean,
you have to, as I said,
I'm not a really extrovert person at all.
I'm quite shy in many ways.
And it took a real sense of will to get on there and believe
that you have to do this because now you're in the spotlight.
And so we're gonna do it. Don't go being coy about it.
You're going to do it face up. I think everybody does that.
I think I've never known an actress who wasn't that way,
you know? I mean, I think you have to be to, to actually do the job properly.
I mean, walk around and see, I am the greatest actress in the most bet.
David should know, Oh, you're not. Are you fundable human being basically,
that's what you are doing a particular job to the best of your ability
to know about your vulnerability. I never met a great former who was arrogant.
I didn't know. Cause you can't.
Cause you do know that no matter how good you are one day, one day,
it'll all go. You'll fall on your face. But.
Your wife, has she, has she been involved in your questions? Oh,
you should ask her this. You should ask him about,
or she doesn't speak like that. By the way
[inaudible] wife, is she a Royal or.
I think she wrote it, but she's not really no coal miner's daughter.
Has she been doing inputs in your questionnaires or no.
No, no, absolutely not. No. She leaves me alone. I left her alone too.
Absolutely. I mean, you can't do other people's interviews for.
Well, one, one person that that was changed, uh,
by a success in a way,
was George Best the footballer whom you have whom you written your second
book now?
Well, that's, uh, I, I wrote many books,
but I've written two books in a series about people,
particularly new or Mohammed Ali and George Best and best as
their most lovers.
But, but this is, it's a second book about George Best as well.
You wrote about him.
First of all, then I wrote about George Best,
but I've written many books are Mark because I'm a journalist. Basically.
I've been a journalist all my life from writing. I did.
I've been a journalist now for, well,
I started when I was 16 seven when I started until it was just an addition.
It was a, it was a toy. Um, no, so, uh, I D Mo George,
I knew I was in,
I'd started at Granada television in Manchester in 1963 and I was
doing a daily show and I was producing the show and a guy Ron got Patsy and Dan
said to me one day said, uh, uh, we got a new group coming up, uh, from London,
you should interview the lead singer. He said, because he's a bright lad.
And I thought, and he said, get one of the old reporters to do it.
And I thought, no, no report. I want to be famous. Don't mind, I'll do it.
And I did it in my first interview. It was a Jagger that was in 1963.
And from that point on, I liked it so much,
but I actually continued doing it and not producing anymore.
So that was the start of it. So.
So tell me, tell me about George Best because he, he, he,
he was really, I mean, you, you written a book about Jack, but she's his, um,
uh, he was really changed by success.
Well,
George is 17 years of age when he came to Manchester and the grunting
wonderful team of they have them. Matt Busby was the Niger mum.
Must've been looking since the aircraft was killed. All his players.
He was looking for one man who actually,
he thought tick him into Europe to win the European cup.
And he found him in this 17 year old wave from Northern Ireland.
It was about the shape of a cocktail stick.
When I met him and the weight about four stone, I, a bit of an exaggeration,
but he was a child. But by God, he was a tough child. More than that,
he was a beautiful child. I've never seen him more Hanson player in my life.
The George was in every sense, physically, emotionally the love, you know,
and for the first time in Manchester,
I remember going there after George had been playing for about a year,
you thought what's different. What was different?
Was that the noise of the crowd, there was a soprano section, you know,
baritones and basses and tenors. And then all of a sudden, you know,
this over the top.
And none of those are the girls that he attracted to the game.
And from that point on, I knew football had changed. He changed it.
And he was as much about being that, that kind of representation of sex symbol.
If you like,
as it wasn't about any gift to the hand of football as a footballer,
he had all the gifts. He was a wonderful.
But, but could, could he, could he handle that stardom.
Who could, is a 17 year old boy from, from,
from the back door of Northern Ireland.
He had no training at all in this,
he was a kid who went to a local school and he just had us a blind gift.
And he just had the most beautiful face. And of course, you know,
both in the end conspired to actually bring him down, but I'll tell you what,
you had a wonderful time.
I never knew a football or a better time with George.
You must remember it. Yeah, for sure. Um, man, um,
I grew up in the seventies, late seventies, George Patton was a legend.
He was like, the first of course Pele was like a superstar,
but George Pez was sort of the modern.
Pop star football player want to get into the argument who is better than
Maradona, Pele, George, best as a celiac. And they're all great players.
What George had, what those didn't have the sex appeal.
And that was part of his problem. Parts of the visit bill. I mean,
he had a huge female following and I've never seen anybody attract women
like, like George [inaudible] all kinds of shapes and sizes. It was amazing.
And he was besotted by them too.
And he, he became a heavy drinker. Yeah.
We all drank. We all drank of that in those days. I mean, uh, I remember, uh,
football or walking through the plate glass doors of Granada,
television leave and impression there.
But that was the only time times I got out of, I said,
be careful with the drink. I mean, before that, it didn't matter.
I see people drunk out their heads on television that it used to happen in those
days. It was a bit like the wild West, you know, uh,
on George's part of that culture, football is ranked food.
We all drank and it was.
Did you have the drunken guests on as well?
Oh, I had one or two drugs. I never drank myself. Um, this is true.
Cause I dead, you know, it's like you go on television, get the lights on,
you know that. So all that pancakes off and you're gone, you're frazzled.
So I never did that. There are a lot of people did.
And a lot of footballers did too. And, and George of course got the money.
He had the, the fame, he had all the adulation and.
I knew it was, it was, it made him.
Giddy. And in that sense, and he was a tragic figure. In the end,
it became a sad drunk as people do. He became Flawn.
He became defenseless. Uh,
and you'll see him in a pub and you'd walk away because you didn't want to face
the fact that your mate or your love was actually looking less than
pretty did did.
Yeah. I mean, he was your, your not only a favorite guest of yours,
but he was a friend also.
It was, it was a great friend.
He used to come down to our house and he used to always Chuck a bag of balls
into the room for my three sons to play with them.
And they'd play football all day long.
And I'd sometimes get some of my friends similar,
more famous to come down and see him because they like to bring their kids down
and he would ignore them. Totally. But he'd play with their kids.
He play football with them. And Michael, my son was here today.
It was a wonderful story. He was about six or seven.
And the next on the set is Sunday. George played football within our guard.
And then the next day he went to school on his own to a Catholic school and
none. And she said to the children, what did you do this weekend?
They'll say we went for grinding. The part of the data and resigned. He said,
yes, Michael, what did you do? So I played football with George Best. She said,
don't tell terrible lies back. What's an awful thing to do.
I actually made her sat in a corner. So this was be great.
She'll send it to the next time that George Best came down. Mike said to George,
George had got detention because of you told him the story. George said,
get me that football. It's going to football, white football to sister song.
So this is to tell you that Michael did not tell a lie. He did play football.
Me love George. Best. I took it to
[inaudible].
Oh, did you have, did you experience that,
that moment when with George, uh, you, when you,
when you tried to avoid him that you didn't want to be with him.
The ultimate betrayal, isn't it, that's the ultimate thing you Scott.
And she was that sort of thing. But yes,
there were times when I didn't want to be with him the times I wanted to do,
I suppose this associate myself from him, but they started that with all drugs.
Isn't it, you know, they're highly amusing themselves,
but not to you after a while, particularly if you're not drunk with them,
that's the problem. But not too often. I mean, I think our men,
and then I couldn't go to the hospital to watch him because I've been told I may
turn yellow and all that. And he was dying and I didn't want to see that.
I mean, you know, we'll do ward, you know, and I was away in Australia when,
when he died. And, uh, and uh,
I still feel bad about being away when he did die. But, uh,
but nonetheless, I mean, uh, we more than made up for it when we were together,
when he was not drunk, you know, and when he was in his prime and, uh,
and I treasure moments of his,
the social never forget as a player I'm as the man.
Did you, did you ever yourself drink that?
Not that much, obviously, but as much more than you should.
No, I did. I mean, I, I, when I was, I was, uh,
not far off being an alcoholic at one point I was drinking far too heavily.
What kind of [inaudible] fall down my throat. I mean, I was,
and I was, uh,
I had this discipline where I wouldn't drink after Thursday in a week,
so didn't do a show on Saturday.
So I had three days where I suppose that kept me sane. But, uh,
I went, I sought psychiatric help and, uh, I had that and, uh,
I went to a doctor and, and all of that. And then he just put me straight.
He said, listen, at the end,
it's up to you is they do want to keep on drinking and maybe die from brain
can lose your career. And I thought that's a no-brainer,
but I knew drunk. Still think of it that way.
You see the thing of the good times that having,
how did Mary handle it very well? I mean, she was big pitiless.
She, someone said to me, I mean, she was the real reason why I changed.
She said to me, do you know what your problem is when you're drunk?
And I said, no, she said, you're ugly driver.
[inaudible] slightly vain. But they tried every other possible.
Every other word, you know, the ugly. It was the, I thought, no, I'll tell you
I'm not. And, uh, so I stopped. It wasn't as easy as that.
It never is, but, but you have to, if you've got any, any sense.
But do you think that it was the pressure from stardom that made you drink or
was it.
No, that's the easy way out. That's bold, frankly. I mean,
I'm sort of that's that's bull. Um, I, um, no, I didn't. I mean,
that's a convenient excuse and, uh, there's no good doing that. I mean,
if you start making convenient, convenient excuses like that,
you'd never going to stop. So why do you think you'd rank why I was unhappy?
I was unhappy or I was happy. I don't know which, I mean, I,
I was in a convivial situation. I mean, I came out to fleet street.
The police treated that's the street of dreams used to be for all the
newspapers. Exactly. And when I was down there,
it was a bit like Dodge city without the sheriff. I mean,
he was full of saloons,
attempting maidens and drink and all that so that you couldn't help,
but go there. So by the time I got into television, I had had a up, you know,
I was, uh, I was a seasoned drinker, so I had to learn to be a,
not to be that that was the difference, but there's,
that's where I'd served my apprenticeship and fleet street.
It's a, it's not a healthy life journalist misery.
No, not really. I mean, it it's, uh, I can't think of any other life,
actually. I know I've done all my life since I was 16. So I.
Actually there, when, how Marshall's plane went down one year,
when in Congo, you went to Congo to meet hamartia.
I knew that I needed to be with the biggest mistakes of my life.
I was standing on a brilliant defense with an old Germans called silver veins
live from a dead express. He was coming out, leaving the Congo I was going in.
And, uh,
we saw this plane Cobain and we saw two or three people get up over about half a
mile away and all the press, he arrived at that sort of thing.
And I said to Sue I a while I said, you're not going to write anything. He said,
what I'm going to write. I saw that Michelle's arrival. Did you see dark?
How much shall.
We say? I shouldn't? Yes. I said.
You didn't think you saw a man, the plane, could you identify Madame Michelle?
I said, no. He said, that's why I've not failed.
But of course he was the only one who didn't fall.
And I'm sure that of course is dead. He crashed 10 miles away.
Great lesson to a young girl.
Um, tell me, Michael, uh, who,
who was your Holy grail? Who was the one you never got on your show?
Sinatra? [inaudible].
Um, I think it's an officer is the greatest artist,
a greatest singer of any man and woman in the
20th back, the 20th century, uh, uh,
wonderful, wonderful singer. I tried very hard.
I got for friendly with a van who wrote songs from called Sammy con.
And he took me to a party in, in, in,
in LA and I met Sinatra and some artists
[inaudible] Mike Parkinson. He does a great talk show and I'm buying it,
Mike Frank and all that. So I went there and then I wonder around this,
the suddenly went off somewhere else. And I wonder, I didn't know anybody,
but me and Frank Sinatra. And so I thought about half an hour got go away.
So I went up the synopsis that I'm living now,
it started nice to met you and hopefully I'll see you in London. He said,
sure thing, David, he said, I really made a Mark here.
Well, um, then I have to say, uh, Michael, that,
uh, you are missing the ultra. Thank you so much for, uh,
for being here tonight.
[inaudible] hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.